congratulations on the movie
uh you guys all did such a wonderful job
i think fans are going to love it
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
and maybe things that you won't read in
the press notes what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of respect
we rehearsed a lot before we actually
started filming a lot of times when you
film
uh you start uh and you're filming and
rehearsing all at the same time but
there was a lot of rehearsal that
happened
prior to the film starting to actually
shoot
uh its principal um photography and
that was very important i think for me
it gave me a chance to really bond with
sky
which was necessary as we worked out our
you know
what we were going to be singing and how
we would be singing it and um to spend
time with her
prior to um beginning the filming
process so i think there was a level of
um
of intimacy for all the all the
characters involved prior to beginning
uh to actually shoot because there had
been that
time of rehearsal prior to that it's not
often i get to talk to someone who's won
six tony awards
um and i'm just gonna which is amazing
since nobody's recording this and it's
just you and me
uh which one do you think was your
favorite
because no one's recording it it's just
um right right
i don't i don't have a favorite um i've
been asked this question before i don't
have a favorite because
um it's like children i mean although
people say oh yes sometimes you do have
a favorite child
um each each role and each role that
i've won a tony for is
special to me for different and very
specific reasons so they're not
i don't have a favorite they're all
special to me in a different way it's
probably boring answer
no no i i completely get it well let's
do a different question
if you could go back in time tonight or
today
and go back to one of those performances
one of those six performances
um and redo it tonight just you know to
read
to take it in again which one might you
want to go back to
i think i would probably want to go back
to um
billie holiday and just try again
um that was a that was one of the most
difficult roles i've ever had
uh to play and every night i i i would
at the end of it i would feel like oh i
could have done this or oh i missed this
or oh i didn't
feel fully settled in to what she was
going through in that moment
so um even though i've done that role
three different times on broadway in
london
and in the film version i i feel like
i'm not done with her i feel like i
still need to go back and work on it
i i i sort of understand um
uh i am very excited for julian fellowes
um
uh the gilded age uh and i heard that it
takes place in the same universe as
downton abbey
i don't know if that is is that true
well
uh it takes place at the very end of the
19th century going into the 20th century
so
gilded age is a little bit before that
um uh because this is the 1890s
so um yeah so we're a little bit before
that but
um it's an era that uh there's a lot
that went down that a lot of people i
mean you know we just we don't know our
history like we should and julian
fellowes is really
um done his research and it's a it's a
it's an incredible world to sort of step
into
um i've always wanted to be a part of a
costume drama and
and and now i am and the wonderful thing
about it is there's a whole
the the black community in new york
during that time
was a was a very specific society that
has not really been portrayed on film
yet
and so i'm so excited that we're going
to get a chance to see that and to see
you know their world um our world what
it was during that time because so many
people just think you know
black people were slaves and then they
were servants and then you know then
they were fighting for their rights and
now here they are i mean there's there's
so much
um that needs yeah i mean it's it's the
ignorance is there
so you know as sherlyn ifill the
president of the naacp legal defense
fund said you know you use the tools in
your toolbox to um
change the narrative to create the
narrative and so that's happening here
with the gilded age so i'm really
pleased that people are going to see
that
and it's not made up this is historic
this is actually this stuff actually
happened
cannot wait again congrats on this film
um i wish you nothing but the best have
a fantastic day
thank you you too